[موسيقى]
وهنحيكم من جديد يوصل النظام الايراني
سياسه الاعدام في حق العزيزي من الشخصيات
البارزه وهذه المره مع المواطن البريطاني
الايراني علي رضاء اكبر احد مستشاري
شمخاني سابقا بتهمه التجسس ونقل اسرار
الدوله الى بريطانيا فالنظام الايراني وان
برر قراره بتحركات اكبر في عهد الرئيس
السابق حسن روحاني حينما قدم زجاجه عطرا
لامين المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي ان
هدفها الحصول على معلومات سريه عن الدوله
غير ان تصيب الصوتي لاكبر كشف المستور
ونفى كل التهم الموجهه اليه بخصوص التجسس
ونقلي اسرار الدوله حيث اكد ان الاتهامات
غير صحيحه في اشاره لتعرضه لتعذيب
والتحقيق في مراكز السريه لجهاز
الاستخبارات
من طرف النظام الايراني الا انه ساهم في
عوده التوتر حول العديد من القضايا
الخلافيه والملفات الشركات بين لندن
وزهران حيث ادانت عده دول تنفيذ السلطات
الايرانيه حكما بالاعدام بحق علي رضا اكبر
وصفه اياه بالعمل القاسي والجبان ونفذه
نظام مجري
اعلام السريه
[موسيقى]
هنا ناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي نعمل لندن
المحامي
من اوسلو عماره نسائيه عضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوزيه اهلا بكم يا اسمحالي ان
ابدا من وصله معك يا استاذ عمار استاذ
عمار اذا ما اشرنا الى ان النظام الايراني
لا يقدم على اجراء بطريقه مجانيه وبان
وراء كل اجراء هناك رساله رسالته من بعض
اعدامه لعلي رضا اكبر موجه هذه بريطانيا
للمجتمع الدولي او للداخل الايراني
تحيه لك ومشاهد الكرام والضيفك الكريم في
طبيعه الحال اعتقد ان الرساله التي اراد
ان يوجهها النظام الايراني هي بالدرجه
الاولى
موجهه الى الداخل اي وخاصه على
خلايا بريطانيا تريد تصنيف الحرس الثوري
كما منظمه ارهابيه فهو اراد ايصال هذه
يعني اننا قدمنا على هذا الاعدام فاذا تم
تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه يعد ذلك
رد فعل من الجانب البريطاني واذا لم يتم
قال ان هذا انتصار سياسي هو انتصار لنا
ولكن ايضا ان هناك ايضا حديث عن التصفيات
التي تدور داخل المجموعات همم السياسيه
السياسيه عسكريه اقتصاديه همم داخل النظام
الذي هي معظمها من قاده الحرس الثوري همم
يقال ان هذه المجموعه اريد بها ان ان تضرب
مجموعه علي شمخاني داخل ال- همم السلطه
كما ان ان ايضا حديث نور على ان ربما ان
علي شمساني اراد يضحي بهذا ال- ال- المقرب
منه علي اكبر صالحه ويجعله همم كبشه فداء
التكه هناك كثيره وهذا الملفات اسمه
الكثير من الغموض كما ان جاء في الاخبار
عن زجاجه عطر وخميس وهذه الاشياء
همم تلاحقت بخصوص هذا الموضوع ولكن استاذ
امجد ضيف يقول بانه بمجرد ان فكرت
بريطانيا في طرح موضوع الحرس الثوري على
قائمه العقوبات تحركت همم ايران
واعدمت احد مواطنها مبدئيا هل تلقفت
بريطانيا هذه الرساله وهنا يطرح موضوع
العقوبات هل هذه العقوبات التي
ادرجتها او تفكر في ادراجها بريطانيا
اتت ب همم اهداف او اثبتت شيء لنظام او
حتى المجتمع الدولي
لا طبعا لا العقوبات يعني اصبحت اييه
ايران الان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ايران
اصبحت لديها المناعه من هذه العقوبات
وليست فعاله كما يتصور البعض
ايران تمكنت من الاستمرار بدون تاثر ملموس
لفتره طويله ولذلك هذا يعني اقل ما يمكن
القيام به من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه هل
كان هذا الحدث رد فعل ربما كان رد فعل لكن
هو رده فعل غير متوازنه همم هو تصعيد ولكن
تصعيد في الاتجاه همم الخطا لانه همم رغم
انها هذه المساله ممكن تكون تصفيات حساب
بين مراكز قوى ايرانيه الا انها عرضت
ايران
لانتقاد يعني همم حقوق واسع بالعالم من
قبل الحكومات ومن قبل المنظمات
يعني بميزان الحسابات اعتقد ان ايران هي
الخاسره
لانها هكذا حدث عن ايران صحيح ولكن بميزان
حسابات من بميزان الحسابات الدوليه فئران
خاسره كما تقول ولكن بميزان حسابات ايران
همم هل تعب بهذه الانتقادات تعتقد
الى حد كبير وخاصه انها تفاوض بالملف
النووي وان ايران تريد ان تحسن من همم
الصوره الدوليه لها ايران تحاول ان تتنصل
حتى من مساعدتها لروسيا في الحرب
باوكرانيا وذلك لان ايران تسعى جاهده الى
ان تعود خسارتها بالماضي وتحسين وضعها من
خلال الدخول بهذه الاتفاقيه وعدم تورتها
بالنزاعات خارج منطقه ايران يعني ايران
بالعاده التنفي اي تدخل خارجي لا اقول لها
دخل ولكن تحاول ان تنفي ان تكون ماكره في
تدخلها اما الان فا هذا الشخص وهو اصلا من
المسؤولين في ايران وخدم كنائب وزير
الدفاع يعكس ان ايران لم تفعل ذلك لكي
تكيد او تاكيد المملكه المتحده نتيجه انها
وضعت الحرس الثوري على القائمه همم
السوداء لكن لحسابات داخليه وذلك الارجح
وطريقه الاعدام السريعه هي بالعدم اتبعه
من قبل الدول التي لا تريد ان يتسرب اخبار
تكشف براءه الشخص الذي يتم اعدامه يعني
هناك واعتقد هناك ما يقال او يشع بان
المدعي العام هو من كان يروج للاعدام بشكل
عام سياسه الاعدام ولكن هناك مراكز قوى
تدعم او او تريد ان تضرب هذا الجناح من
مركز قوى في ايران خلا
داخليه بخصوص هذا الموضوع ولكن حتى لا
نزيح عن موضوعنا الاساسي د- اا استاذه
امجد حضرتك ترى بان هذه العقوبات لم تؤثر
بتاتا في النظام الايراني العقوبات التي
طالت الحرز الثوري طالت قيادات ايرانيه
ترى بانها لم تؤثر فيها هل تتفق مع ضيفي
استاذ بان هذه العقوبات وان طالت وان ثقلت
فانها لا تؤثر مباشره على النظام
نعم امجد ساعود لك السؤال للاستا استاذ
عيسى
المجتمع الايراني كيف الاستاذ يقول انها
لم تؤثر العمله الايرانيه منهاره المجتمع
الايراني المفتقه الاقتصاد الايراني شبه
منهار فالحقوبات لها تاثيرها كما انها حتى
لها تاثير على نفس مؤسسه الحرس الثوري لان
هذه المؤسسه الحرس الثوري هي اداءها في
معظمه اقتصادي ولديها كثير من المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه وان العقوبات لها تاثير ولها
تاثير كبير لها تاثير سياسي لها تاثير
اجتماعي لها تاثير همم اقتصادي ولكن
النظام الايراني يتظاهر بانه لا يفترس
لهذه العقوبات لحفظ الماء وجهه في الداخل
وتبرير اخطائه في السياسه الخارجيه التي
هي الناجمه عن عيد الوجيته وسياسته
وتعامله مع الدول وتعاملها الخاطئ مع مع
دول العالم العالم خاصه ليبرر لاولئك
الذين لا زالوا من انصار من الشعوب
الايرانيات انه في الطريق الصحيح انه في
طريق مكافحه كما يزعمون الاستكبار
والاستعمار والقوه الكبرى والشيطان الاكبر
وهذه
التوابل لم تترك اي اثر علينا ولكن في
الواقع على ان
مثلا ازمه انقطاع الغاز الايران التي
تنتهي
ارتفاع
يعني مستوى المعيشه هذا يؤثر في الشعر
ولكننا لم نرى مثلا المراقبون ما الذي
يقولونها استاذ تس- يقولون بان هذه
العقوبات لم تغير في سلوك النظام وتعاطيه
مع الملفات الدوليه هنا السؤال
منذ بدايه الثوره على اساس انه يتعامل
وفقا لجيته الصلبه التي تبناها هذه
الافكار التي بعظمها هي وفقا لايدلوجيه
الدينيه السياسيه والناتج عن الفكر
السياسي فهو لا يستطيع تغيير وان اراد
يعني حاله الطقس في النهايه تتفق مع ضيفه
بان هذه العقوبات همم لم تؤثر في النظام
الايراني هذا ما قاله منذ قليل الاستاذ
امجد واعتبرتك بان هذا الطرح غير مفهوم
الايراني على
الدوله
فكيف لا لم تؤثر على تسير الامور عاجز عن
توفير الغاز للمصانع البيوت والان
والالغاز مقطوع عن عشره محافظه من
المحافظات البارده في ايران فكيف لم يؤثر
على ادائه نعم على سلوكه تعامله سياسته
الخارجيه لم ياثر ولكن على ادائه نعم هناك
تاثير كبير كبير
استاذ امجد سؤال مطروح في الواقع والذي هو
قديم متجدد همم ان كانت هذه العقوبات لا
تاتي نتيجه فعليه فيما يخص سلوك ايران
العداء في المنطقه
وسلوك كذلك اتجاه بعض الملفات الدوليه ما
الحل
انا اعتقد ان الامور وخاصه بهذا الملف
تحديدا ال اعدام اليوم والاعدامين
السابقين كان الرده الفعل غير قويه
الاعدام الاخير لم تكن قويه لانه من
الصعوبه ان تتعامل بريطانيا بالتحديد مع
هكذا ملف كون ان الشخص يحمل الجنسيه
البريطانيه ولكن ايضا يحمل الجنسيه
الايرانيه وكان يخدم همم يعني رجل الحكومه
او رجل دوله في حكومات ايران همم
الماضيه وكانت كما الشرق نائب وزير الدفاع
ولذلك هناك صعوبه ولكن بريطانيا والدول
الغربيه بامكانها ان ان ان ان ان ان تعمل
بالعقوبات الفرديه وهي بدات اليوم بتوجيه
العقبه او الطلب بالتوجيه العقوبات للنائب
العام الايراني وكذلك العمل بشكل جدي
لمقاطعه ايران خارج خارج ايران يعني ليس
قتل الصادرات والواردات
الايرانيين لكن تعمل بمثلا بسحب الثقه من
ال- ال- النظام الايراني باغلاق السفارات
مثلا هذه هناك اسبقيات باغلاق الصفرات نعم
تم اا دعوه السفير البريطاني مؤقتا
للتباحث معه ولكن انا اعتقد ان هذه خطوه
يعني خجوله الى حد كبير عندما هناك دليل
قاطع يعني رئيس الوزراء رئيس السوناكي
يقول هذا همم يعني عمل وحش همم تقوم به
ايران ولذلك لما لا يقوم همم
بيرده فعل لائق بهذا الموضوع ولذلك ربماهم
الان يعني سيعيدون النظر في هذه العقوبات
او نوعيه العقوبات لتجريد همم الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه ايران من تمثيلها الدبلوماسي في
الخارج
وقطعها تماما
ولكن مهما كان ذلك اعتبرت هذه التحركات
خجوله وصفتها بالخجوله وقلت بانها بدايه
ربما لشيء ما امم استاذ تسائي همم لماذا
يتحرك المجتمع الدولي بطريقه خجوله امام
انتهاكات ايران ما الذي يجعله يخجل من
النظام الايراني
في حال ان الدول الغربيه غيرت مقاربتها
وتعاملها مع النظام الايراني سوف يحصل
فراغ في احداث الخليج هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه ان هناك قضيه تدفق
اللاجئين ايران بلد 100 مليون وربما تكون
هناك امواج همم تشهد امواج امواج من
اللاجئين على اوروبا واوروبا ملف اللاجئين
مهم لديها هو همم يحفظ باهميه كبيره خاصه
في سياسه الاحزاب وسياسه الداخل هذه
النقطه الثانيه النقطه الثالثه هو قضيه
الملف النووي والملف الصالح وهذه الاسلحه
المتكدسه لدى نظام الايراني ما هو مصيرها
في حال سقوط النظام الايراني في حال انها
لم تجد بديل اعتقد ان همم
وجدت البديل المناسب للنظام الايراني سوف
تغير مقاربتها
الايراني وتقوم بخطوات اكثر ااا جديه كما
ان الخطوات التي اتخذتها الان رغم انها
توصف خجوله ولكن اعتقد في حال انها تم
تصنيف الحرس الثوري ومنظمه ارهابيه من قبل
بريطانيا وحلفاء الاوروبيين فتلك خطوه غير
مسبوقه وايضا سوف تؤثر على اداء النظام
خاصه
الثوري لديه الكثير من الشركات التي
تستورد من الشركات الاوروبيه بعض القطاع
التي تستخدم في القطاع الاقتصادي
والارتفاع العسكري في الواقعه نقطه طرحتها
استاذ وهي همم حضرتك تعتبر بان المجتمع
الدولي ان توفر له بديل فهو سيعمل بطريقه
همم اكثر صلابه لتغيير هذا النظام ربما
ستكون نقطه للنقاش ولكن ساكتفي معكم بهذا
القدر حتى الان من اصله وعمر منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه ومن لندن الاستاذ
المحامي سيلفي شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]